[Musique]
bon je cherchais barbara avec une gueule
la seule personne que tu vas réussir a
eu payé c'est tout pas de nuit en fait
pas nui sabrina
[Musique]
dans la ville de green day où ils
semblent qu'halloween soit célébré toute
la vie d'une jeune fille qui était
moitié sorcières et qui le jour de
chauffer sur l'anniversaire devrait
choisir entre deux mondes celui des
sorcières de 7 en août et celui des
humains de sésame et cette fille c'est
moi ça primant acceptes tu de renoncer
au chemin de lumière pour suivre le
chemin de la nuit et ce où qu'ils te mec
[Musique]
je peux pas faire ça tu n'as pas choir
je jure de faire venir sabrina tu vas
mourir là sans élite les faits les
filles inutile de me comporter comme des
pestes
une rebelle spelman c'est comme ça que
je les aime mais sorcières
[Musique]
je ne suis pas une mauvaise personne
aux grands maux les grands remèdes en
bronze
moi je m'appelle sabrina fellmann et je
refuse d'inscrire mon nom
à toi l'honneur sabrina avec plaisir
relève toi
[Musique]
où était-il da elle m'a énervé alors je
les tuer et je les enterrés dans le
cimetière
[Musique]